While the Ancient Greeks had their celebrated
Sacred Band of Thebes, a legendarily successful
fighting force made up of all male lovers,
in more modern times the various branches
of the United States military have not been
so accepting of such individuals, which brings
us to the topic of today- that time in the
1980s when the Naval Intelligence Service
invested significant resources into trying
to locate a mysterious woman identified only
as “Dorothy” who seemed to have links
to countless gay seamen.
The plan was to find her and then “convince”
her to finger these individuals so the military
could give them the boot.
This story all starts with a naval crack down
to try to get rid of any gay personnel in
the early 1980s.
One Mel Dahl, who was completely open about
the fact that he was gay when he was questioned
about it upon enlisting in 1980, was kicked
out in 1981 after being interviewed for a
security clearance upgrade and once again
letting the Navy know he was gay.
This time they weren’t so accepting of that
information.
During the course of Dahl’s subsequent legal
battle with the Navy over his discharge, he
noted to the news media that there were quite
a lot of gay men at the Great Lakes base he
had been stationed at.
This information did not go over well with
the military brass who launched a full scale
investigation of the base to try to identify
these individuals.
Specifically, as reported in Conduct Unbecoming:
Gays and Lesbians in the U.S. Military, by
Randy Shilts, the U.S. Navy spent a considerable
amount of money sending investigators to gay
bars in the Chicago area to try to discover
these gay sailors.
During these trips, investigators noticed
that many gay men in the area identified themselves
as “friends of Dorothy”.
The Intelligence Service deduced that “Dorothy”
must be a woman that functioned as a sort
of information hub that gay men could use
to find other gay men.
If they could only find her, they figured
they could convince her to talk, perhaps outing
many of the gay navy personnel in the process,
who in turn, with a little pressure, could
no doubt out many others.
The key was simply to find Dorothy.
Thus, the NIS tasked investigators with returning
to the same gay bars to clandestinely ask
questions about this mysterious woman.
Unfortunately for them, they failed at finding
Dorothy, wasting an amazing amount of taxpayer
money paying investigators to pose as gay
men, drinking and breaking it down in 1980s
era gay bars.
This said, other investigations they conducted
seem not to have been so fruitless, with the
Defense Department noting that, in total,
1,976 members of the various branches of the
U.S. military were kicked out for being gay
in 1981 alone; a reported 55% of these individuals
were ousted from the Navy- all at a massive
cost to U.S. taxpayers.
As noted by one discharged gay Air Force captain
interviewed by Shilts, it cost the Air Force
somewhere in the range of four to five million
dollars to train him when factoring in the
exceptionally high cost of aircraft time in
that training.
(As an interesting aside, for a time it was
perceived that the military was unfairly targeting
gay men, while not cracking down nearly so
hard on lesbians in their ranks.
As a result, in 1990 Vice Admiral Joseph S.
Donnell issued a memo urging his subordinates
to root out lesbians in the Navy, not just
gay men.
As to how lesbians were to be identified,
he wrote, “Experience has shown that the
stereotypical female homosexual in the Navy
is hard-working, career-oriented, willing
to put in long hours on the job and among
the command’s top professionals…”
We can’t make this stuff up.)
In any event, at this point you might be wondering
who exactly was this “Tokyo Rose” of the
gay community and how did she have so many
gay friends?
As it turns out, she was none other than Dorothy
Gale of The Wizard of Oz…
You see, for over a half century now the phrase
“Friend of Dorothy” has been considered
a euphemism for “gay”.
The phrase, sometimes simply abbreviated to
FOD, is believed to have first popped up sometime
in the 1940s as a way for gay men to identify
themselves as such to others without outright
saying it.
As you can imagine, in areas where the laws
of the land and/or the general populace were
strongly against said individuals, being able
to say “I’m a friend of Dorothy” instead
of “I’m gay” was a major boon.
After all, if said individual was speaking
to someone who was also gay, the other person
would probably know exactly what they were
saying.
If not, likely they’d think the individual
knew some woman named Dorothy who they mistakenly
thought was a mutual acquaintance.
While there are alternate speculative theories
as to the origin of the phrase, based on the
evidence at hand, as mentioned, it is generally
thought to have been inspired by the popular
1939 film The Wizard of Oz and/or the 1909
book it is based on.
It is also noted that Judy Garland herself
ultimately became exceptionally popular among
the gay community throughout her adulthood,
while the film is popular for its message
of inclusivity in spite of differences.
To quote the Gay Times on the matter:
Dorothy’s three companions on her trip to
Oz have long been read as gay, and for good
reason.
The Tin Man, the Scarecrow, and the Cowardly
Lion are misfits who do not conform to their
perceived ‘roles’.
The Scarecrow is unable to frighten anything
– crow or otherwise; the Tin Man constantly
needs lubing up; and the Cowardly Lion seems
to prefer mincing to roaring.
This ostracisation is familiar to many gay
guys – who are often accused of being less
masculine than straight guys.
On that note, Dorothy happily accepts the
somewhat effeminate “Cowardly Lion” who
eventually identifies as a “friend of Dorothy,”
and earlier on states, “I’m afraid there’s
no denyin’, I’m just a dandy lion,”
with “dandy” generally referring to an
often effeminate man seen as overly preoccupied
with fashion.
(For more on this, see Why Did Yankee Doodle
Stick a Feather in His Cap and Call It Macaroni?)
Books continuing the story also include similar
themes, characters and moments that likewise
resonate with the LGBT communities.
Most famous of all is a quote from the book,
The Road to Oz, in which Dorothy responds
to a character saying she has “queer friends”
by saying:
The queerness doesn’t matter, so long as
they’re friends.
Of course, the word “queer” here is roughly
understood to be a synonym for “odd” or
“unusual”, but, as with so many other
bits of the books that are not actually thought
to have been references to homosexuality,
it nonetheless struck a chord among gay fans
who responded well to the idea of accepting
someone regardless of how different others
found them- it was their character that was
the only thing that was important.
A mere decade after The Wizard of Oz first
made its debut on the big screen, “Friend
of Dorothy” had become one of the most popular
euphemisms used by gay people to refer to
themselves- a fact the rest of the world were
largely oblivious to, allowing gay people
to discretely identify themselves as such
at a time when doing so may have been illegal
where they lived and/or potentially dangerous.
Unsurprisingly given changing attitudes and
laws today, the phrase “Friend of Dorothy”
isn’t nearly as widely known among those
of the youthful persuasion in the LGBT communities,
and many with a few more years under their
belts have less need to use the phrase than
they once did, so it is dying out somewhat.
However, one place you’ll still occasionally
hear it is aboard cruise ships, where an announcement
like “Friends of Dorothy are meeting in
the lounge on Deck 7 at 8 pm” is sometimes
made.
This is similar to how members of Alcoholic
Anonymous have long announced meetings aboard
cruise ships as a meeting of “Friends of
Bill W”.
This refers to the founder of Alcoholic Anonymous,
William “Bill” Willson.
Similar to the “Friends of Dorothy” announcements,
the idea is to provide a way to announce such
meetings without outing those
who attend.